welcome to this video yet another
episode of this pre World Championship
serious part 11 already so we are
halfway through and it's the war
champions turn again the sheer Arnold
and it's time to go back to the 2007
lawl championships and this is one of
those rare occasions where the World
Championship was decided with the
tournament not with a match and played
in Mexico City September 2007 back then
we had eight players competing in a
double round-robin tournament one of the
players was chrome Nick who was the
world champion at the time and in order
to yeah somehow I'm get to him yeah how
to say in novel world championship
cycles they played this tournament where
chronic was participating and the winner
of the tournament was to be the new
world champion but chrome Nikita um had
the right to immediately challenged the
new title holder should he not win the
tournament then get a match which
happened one year later so I'll add won
this tournament quite convincingly
managed to get two plus four score which
is pretty good you know in this type of
format plus 4 14 rolls it's quite
comparable to them candidates tournament
that this year has been played I've been
played in New in London where we also
had eight players tal round robin and
Karzai cromley both reached plus three
so Arnold it's plus for us a really good
score so let's look at one of the games
that made via the world champion and the
took the title that he still holds okay
we have one e4 as usual in term Grisha
come los three relies on one e5 and the
night off against you for he also plays
a mother
openings but they're mostly a surprise
bubbles yeah we get the Royal nada
pretty much exclusive exclusively place
the Rue La Paz once in a while he
surprises with the Scott sure but quite
rarely so we got a normal main line here
where I Grisha castles here to get the
opportunity to play the marshal attack
I'm honored quite frequently allows the
marshal he has some some ideas prepared
once in a while to to test like but
nowadays it's quite uncommon to to allow
the marshal as black seems to be in good
shape mostly white um relies on moves
like Age 3 a 4 so God entire marshals or
even playing d3 earlier if you go dear
through here you could play that it's
not a bad move then you should rather
play D through here and probably save
this this move ok but let's see what we
got in the game was a 4 immediately
attacking it was also a favorite of
Casper rose yeah I don't think he ever
allowed the marshal he always went for
entire marshals ok before nowadays the
Maine moose bd3 yeah black an important
thing is that Bishop d7 is not such a
great move because um you have it on b7
to put pressure on e4 but the item never
will play d4 here quickly but will cover
the pawn and then this Bishop is a bit
it is a bit misplaced so before as
normal all normal moves and black goes
for this Knight a5 c5 maneuver very well
known since yeah well I more than 100
years this maneuver not in this precise
position but in similar positions black
make sure that this night allows the
support to move to participate in the
central struggle so c3 at the end that's
the SD for that while wants to play 96
back and here there are there many
possibilities white also had tried them
slow moves like let's say night f1 or
well let's say 94 was like that ana
tries a new idea he plays d 4
immediately striking in the center which
was the novelty at the time not a
novelty that should really am yeah put
blacks positions position under ahoy
shouldn't a danger black too much but it
adds a new twist to this known type of
position yeah black now decided to to
change the pawn structure and go to UM
gap a non-symmetrical bone structure he
took on c3 and now decided to capture on
deform it is playable but leading to UM
can at least them if you ask me to a
debatable structure it is in fact very
difficult in this game to exactly
pinpoint where at which at which exact
position um yeah grew shocked got into
trouble I mean I'm not spoiling much
here if I say that
she one of the game it's a bit of bit of
a given in this series so not a much not
a big spoiler here but the thing is it's
very hard i try to figure out and even
use some published analysis it's hard to
figure out where blacks problem is later
where word come from okay let's let's
check what happen tip late night to
before yeah okay attacking the bishop it
retreated to a safe square on b1 also
covering here and now black played
Bishop to g4 so just developing this
bishop this is basically the only place
that this Bishop has b7 doesn't make
much sense it's just a look at this this
Bishop is just biting on granite so
Bishop g4 and now h3 is played Bishop h5
yeah one problem that it's going to go
into pop up is that this Bishop doesn't
have many squares I don't know place g4
and to what that's black also it could
have captured on a three but this is of
course and move that you don't really
want to play giving white the two
bishops what already enjoys a pretty
good center so you don't want to give
him the bishop am okay g4 yeah this is
important and move that you really
shouldn't be afraid of and there are no
sacrifices available because black
doesn't have any attacking pieces of
bishop g6 is the only move and now d 5
yeah and this is the pawn structure that
is so interesting it is quite similar to
the to the mall in benoni of course the
be pawns are missing which means that
this is possible outpost for the night
and then all posts that it's not so
easily
challenged the missing vporn he is
really a problem and also take note that
black as the night on before and if you
have watched the whole series you you
will probably remember the game that are
already showed are not against kamsky
but the night was placed on before but
it really was a problematic piece
because it didn't I didn't do much and
more yeah and even the addition to also
hindered likes play another issue that
black faces is that this Bishop is yeah
it's not a great piece it's a it's
attacking me for but it's also piece
that can get into trouble I had a
similar position once against them and
in the Dutch league against Dutch junior
player and she it was a girl she she had
moved the night later in a in a similar
position and then went f4 I'd this
Bishop on g6 really got into trouble
imagine f4 f5 winning a piece so on this
is some really a problematic piece on g6
so is this a good position for Wiseman
yeah I like it but in fact despite all
general considerations black seems to be
okay if he now would have played rugby 8
this is the only position where you can
really clearly improve on Grizzles play
rugby ageism better than what he played
he played on 97 rugby 8 is based on a
tactical idea the problem is of white
now plays Knight c4 then black has this
needs trick in fact using this Bishop so
wyd cannot play night c 4 immediately he
can he can try something else improving
the position but he cannot play this
this
good news so this is what grew shock
should have played to prevent night c4
and in fact this seems okay ninety-seven
now ever after 94 doesn't really help
the night at XD six so black girl always
has to watch out for this this pawn this
of course the yeah the problem part in
the Benoni and here the night texted
immediately white also has ideas to
increase the pressure so black really
should get rid of the night quickly
played rugby aid first yeah this idea is
still in the game but after Bishop f4 it
is not possible this is protected yeah
he went Knight b6 to get rid of the
night and Allen just captured that ft2
also looks like a good move but after
Bishop f6 you need to be cautious
something like this is rather
embarrassing it's a tricky position with
those two bishops something like that
just wins for black so why just took
this the better movement takes a 92 and
of course the nitrous is heading for for
the c-4 square note that in this
position quite similar to the hockey
game this night on before can never move
anywhere feel those squares are taboo
would never never was going to go down
and of K it limits White's bishop it's
not like that it's a bit of those pieces
somehow can't cancel each each other out
but it also means that the B file is
some
no big achievement for black because the
night is just blocking it one issue is
of course that this rook is on a one but
it can be used by I three in fact now
it's a black smooth I think a Grisha
probably should have played Bishop f6
the idea okay first attacking the rook
it probably would go to a three wells
and then continue not sure maybe maybe
even Bishop d4 serve as a move I think
this is better than what he played
however what is pretty surprising you
played Bishop to g5 and what I find
really remarkable is that after the
capture this is what on a plate Queen
takes Knight c4 text both and at first
you think okay why not 96 this was
played why not 96 yeah there's a very
embarrassing news a double attack out of
nowhere so cannot take the six but a lot
has a very good simple movie plays Queen
d2 and what I find a really amazing in
this position um yeah black now doesn't
really have much else than to to
exchange Queens I mean you if you want
to go back let's say here it's a it's e5
maybe you can even prepared a buddy 5s
is a good move immediately breaking
through so we shall we exchanged night
takes and f6 so he wants to get some
room for this bishop and what I find
really remarkable us if you give this
position to to an engine like even
Houdini best engine around it simply
fails to recognize that white is better
at this position
I don't I don't really understand what
the computer is doing its evaluating
this is about equal really 0 0 0 or 0 0
5 or something like that equal and this
is just wrong I don't really understand
what the what the machine is doing why
is white better yeah because of this
weakness on d6 the night is always
attacking this weakness and black needs
to use a piece to defend it at the same
time he has problems with ever using his
night again it doesn't have a square and
a 5 is a move you don't want to play as
night c-4 would immediately attack the
spawn other than that a 5 intending
night a 62 c 7 28 or where do you want
to go just an unlucky piece and white
place 94 f form and just push us
everything forward slowly i think here
white has a definite advantage even if
the computer says is equal i think a
strong strong player would agree that
only white can be better here maybe it's
a it's a defensible position but it's
something some position it's a position
where white is much much easier to play
and in fact i think white is just better
I you really need to um yeah to
understand that even with I don't know
3,000 something rating Houdini sometimes
isn't right in some strategical kind of
positions it simply doesn't doesn't get
the essence what's going on ok let's see
what happens and you would see that that
Alan's play is pretty convincing a place
Nazi for rock d 8 + f4 as mentioned
gaining space whereas blacks plain black
can simply only sit tight and do nothing
while white is just expanding slowly and
preparing breakthroughs
play Division to f7 Andrew k3 this is of
course a great move to to swing the rook
over the well-known look left next
counterplay would be the B file but he
cannot cannot ever get anything there
and the g5 yeah this is an interesting
move black go some yeah sort of goes for
a preemptive strike before white plays
h4 and g5 he recognized that just doing
nothing we probably not work in the long
run and tries to to gain some space on
the kingside himself but yeah white has
a typical reply it plays each form just
immediately increasing the pressure on
the pawn and yeah it's it's difficult
for black not to caption when h6 is just
a very very passiveness it took on a
form it's okay so it's okay and now
we'll get three note that how nicely
this rook gets into play it's very it's
a very static way to play yeah I played
Bishop to eat attacking the spawn Luke
takes and King g7 yeah and now how
should white continue yeah honor the son
no playing the next couple of Muslim
gather is very strong play I mean he
played a very good game anyway but the
the next phase of the games was a very
very nicely played he now played the
move h5 and this is very strong
especially considering that the yeah the
normal let's say a way to play here
would be g5 it's the
the most obvious way to play getting rid
of the f porn and then use the pawn but
h5 is just strong for concrete reasons
g5 is not really a yes not really a
forceful enough of you if you look at
this let's say something like that black
can even consider two claims like Bishop
to g6 it's just not as forceful let's
have a look h5 and now a black took on a
for an understandable decision if you go
h6 this is important White has rook
everyone and we'll get to get to the
pawn
so we shall grab the pawn cannot wage
Texas was what's the point black
immediately is forced to do something
with the king he cannot really letter
the H porn stay on the board so he took
it this is check useless because of the
check yeah it took it took the pond at
John Luke f6 so white quickly managed to
organize this breakthrough and we'll get
to the d6 bond and of course of this
faults white will have two passes in the
center play g5 first cementing the look
um yeah if you if you take here then
Bishop to b5 is some still a defense
maybe not a sufficient one but it
considerably make some White's tasks
harder probably need to take and now you
have this problem only one pawn left and
it's not an easy technical task g5s is
just wrong white also intends to keep
the night of the board who gave aid and
he just knocked up t6 now I'm Bishop b5
was the splenium no no Bishop b5 doesn't
help much that's 93 to f5 the rock is
not hanging on d6 he played Bishop c295
a good continuation centralizing this
piece and intending night Rock d7 check
so why the service is in excellent shape
and probably should win they drew care
for probably a grecian also wasn't
terrible time pressure as usual is
really a Time Trial addict Luke f6 yeah
just very nicely played relying on those
little tactics check
so black cannot capture it so go away
and now d 6 this is the winning pawn the
deep bone captured and took on if of
course white needs to calculate
precisely but chances just flawless game
check and rookie seven yeah no White's
ideas okay the dipole and there's also
this kind of idea getting the knight to
f6 with a meeting attack yeah black
played rock d8 the pawn is covered yes
you for and now seven yeah I know it's
all over rocky a check as a terrible
threat black really doesn't have for any
defense went for repair for look
everyone then check after this it's
pretty much over check it here we shook
resigned after King g8 check this check
just wins rook and white will also get a
new queen with me to follow shortly a
very a very nice game it's just the kind
of game which just flows naturally from
right from the beginning we're probably
here with 97 gree Shaka got into trouble
rugby aid really was stronger and here
this is the position where white simply
enjoy some a lasting advantage ID he
just played this so nicely at all and
it's all a natural flow you can need to
get rid of the Queen's this also makes a
much sense regarding or in regards to
the King position getting rid of the the
Queen's they are traded and now it's
just a one-way street always against the
six
and using the big space advantage I'm
really amazed that Houdini doesn't
understand this position quite quite
amazing but it sometimes happens i think
i have recognized in some weird
positions the computer simply doesn't
yeah it doesn't grasp the long term um
strategical implications it did they are
less and less occurrences where you can
really say okay the computer doesn't
really get what's going on but this is
this is interestingly enough one of them
if you don't believe me try to get hold
of a strong play and getting show in
this position that you will say that
white is better and prediction all right
I hope you enjoyed the game a very nice
strategical win and executed beautifully
by a bishop alright thanks for watching
I'll be back tomorrow with a console
game thanks